we've seen a lot of viral deadpool stuff
recently including that skull people
poster but people are still clamoring to
see more of Suicide Squad will it be
good well the latest images are so it's
promising I'm Kate and this is your game
spot news update back in July fans got
to see the first trailer for Suicide
Squad last week a new image was released
for the film as well today the director
revealed a new poster for the film and
that fans will be getting a new trailer
as well in addition the independent had
a look at ten other posters for the film
featuring the characters that will be
featured on the team the film due to
release on August fifth 2016 follows a
group of villains from the DC Universe
and on impossible missions and stars
jared leto as the Joker Will Smith is
dead shot Margot Robbie as Harley Quinn
as well as in chandras killer croc
katana Slipknot Rick Flagg boomerang and
Diablo all of which are excellent metal
band names even Rick Flagg what do you
think about the poster are you a huge
Suicide Squad fan are you slightly
worried that it looks like it's gonna be
star over substance let me know your
thoughts in the comments or come and
find me on Twitter at how not to draw
thanks for watching and for all your
gaming and entertainment news keep it
games but